Alright, here's the quiz. So just to practice this
concept of what a version space is let's go
through an example. So here we go. Here's the
actual target concept C and, for all possible, it's, mapping
from two input bits to an output bit. And
the two inputs, X1 and X2 can take on all
four possible different values and the outputs are zero
One, one, zero, which is to say the XOR function,
okay so that's what we're trying to learn.
>> Okay.
>> But the training data that we have only has
a couple examples in it. It says well, one training example
says if the inputs are zero and zero. The output is
zero. And if the inputs are one and zero, the output
is one. And, ultimately, we're going to ask questions like,
well, what happens if the input is one and one? What's
the output? Now, since we know that it's XOR, we know
that the answer is zero but that's kind of using information unfairly.
So here's what we're going to do. Here's a set of, a hypothesis set. These are
set of functions. That says, well the output could be just copy X1, negate
X1, copy X2, negate X2, ignore the inputs in return true, ignore the
inputs in return false, take the OR of the inputs,
take the AND of the inputs, take the XOR of the
inputs and then return whether or not the inputs are
equal to each other. And, what I'd like you to do
is, some of these are in the version space and some of them are not for this
training set that I marked here. So, can you
check off which ones are in the version space?
>> I think I can.
>> Awesome. Let's do it.